when players talked about it
hypothetically is there a gay football
player what would you do if if we had a
gay teammate and some of the things have
been said have were low moments for me
because suddenly players say you know if
we have a gay teammate I wouldn't shower
with him you know I wouldn't get changed
in the dressing room and there were some
other things that have been said that I
thought you know I wouldn't want to be
openly gay in the stressing room
[Music]
good good thank you
it's fun to meet you likewise yeah I'm
Thomas hetzberg I'm 40 years old I used
to be a professional football player in
the Premier League played Aston Villa
West Ham and Everton also played in
Germany Italy and the German national
team came out as gay after my career and
ever since life has been brilliant I've
enjoyed it and here I am I'm Jay Daniels
I'm 18 and I am the UK's first male
British football to come out as gay and
I couldn't play for Blackpool and that's
where I've been my whole career I
remember you know being 18 and like okay
this is totally different different time
but I mean really fantastic what you've
done you know when you came out ever
since so pretty amazing so really really
happy to meet you thank you nice to meet
you too when did you come out
so I came out uh January 2014 that was
just after I retired from football my
last Club was Everton and for the last
two or three years of my career I did
think about doing it while I'm still
playing because I knew I could answer a
lot of questions surrounding being gay
openly gay and professional football but
um there's several people I talked to
they they kind of want me to say don't
do it don't do it but after my career
like I said January 2014 I was in a big
enough brave enough to to finally do it
it was a big moment for me but probably
even bigger was the time before talking
to family and friends and and realizing
they're all you know they all were
accepting and and liked me as much as I
did before so it was good you advised
that you didn't come out during your
playing career just why was that
well I'd say the people I talk to they
try to protect me because they didn't
know much they didn't know what it felt
like so they just thought it would be
too much for me the pressure from you
know fans in the dressing room the media
and everything that was always the the
perception uh so not because they felt
uncomfortable they just want to protect
me that was my my thoughts at the time
but there's so much going into it I mean
you know yourself coming out it's not
like okay I wake up one morning and I go
public it's preparing it you know when
I'm going to talk to my teammates when I
speak to the manager to the club family
and everything there was so much and at
the same time of course I had to perform
every day and it became too much and
people took me out of it eventually you
know I talked to a couple of journalists
that I was doing the interview with
and then I was asked to to speak to a
lawyer and the lawyer said to me don't
do it just don't do it and he seemed
like so experienced he's advised you
know prominent people before and he said
look the pressure is too much don't do
it and I came out after the medicine
okay I trust him he probably knows more
than I do so I didn't do it
unfortunately so I came up publicly May
um came out to my family in 2021 to
December so you know that five six month
period was preparing myself getting
everything ready to make sure I did it
in the right way
um and I think around may as well was
when I told all my close friends in my
club as well so
I think I just kept it personal until I
was fully ready and prepared to come out
publicly I have a lot of questions to
that regard because obviously what did
your mum say your sister did they kind
of advise you to go public so my mum and
my sister they said that they knew
straight away that I was already getting
a Mum Mum's Instinct Instinct she knew
um
I think I'm gonna I told my agent as
well
um you know I was going through some
mental health stuff and I was seeing
psychologist and I think everyone was
just asking why and what was the reason
so if that was for me to tell them what
the reason was
um and then it was like look being gay
and playing football hasn't really been
something that you know was
connected and obviously growing up I
never really thought about that and said
it was like you know if you are wanting
to come out publicly then it's such an
amazing thing for you to do and you
should push it but did somebody say to
you like don't go public because there's
no need for it or for whatever reason
yeah
to be fed you know it was that was
always the question that was 50 50 with
my family as well it was you know are
you ready you know you don't want any
Jeopardy to come out of it you don't
want it to affect your career so there's
loads of different reasons why you
should or shouldn't do it but I think
since coming out you know it's been the
best thing and everyone has been
accepting from it so it sure who's the
first person you told in a football
context
I can't really answer that I know the
first person uh was my brother you know
I was telling him I said look I think
something's different here
um but I don't know how to deal with it
uh that was when I talked to him and it
took a while until I took my best mate
but in the football world I never felt
comfortable talking to a teammate that
was that was a bit of a problem because
that was I was a step like I want to
tell a teammate you know it's out there
it's not in my hands anymore
um so I think I told football people
when I came out publicly that's it mine
was my mum and my sister to start with
um and then the day after that was the
welfare guy at football because he knew
something was wrong so telling him he
obviously knew what it was so
um there was obviously the place there
for me to get some help towards that a
few weeks after that was my agent and
then it was
getting Sky Sports in so obviously they
knew and we were filming that
um and then the week I came out was my
football teammates and my friends and
then the world what about getting back
onto the pitch did did you just play the
same did you feel the same or did you
feel like okay the whole world just
watching me now yeah it was a little bit
weird and obviously a little bit of
pressure you know for them it's like
right now we need to see if you actually
can play football and he hasn't just
done this for like a publicity stunt um
obviously that was never the case so
there was a little bit of pressure there
but for me it was his wife I think it
was always like watching my back you
know is someone gonna say something on
the pitch or gonna personally attack me
but I've never experienced that yet so
and then it's become easier yeah 100
yeah because that's something I was
worried about it's like the moment you
say and you tell the guys in the
dressing room it will never be the same
and whether like the performance
wouldn't be as good because he
constantly worried like what do people
think and how do you see you but in the
end it's like okay it's it's been said
but and people move on and that's a good
thing you know it's not that you're the
center of the world all the time in that
moment it feels like everybody's
watching you but then eventually just
kind of you move on you know before I
came out though I had heard things here
and there about being gay you know
banner and adjusting room you know it is
what everyone says but that that
completely stopped and I think that for
me was a nice feeling you know they they
are accepting they realize that you know
I am there and I might take offense to
it why did you choose to come out
publicly and why did you choose to come
out publicly when you did
when I chose to come out publicly
because
um I had people who supported me I
listened to other people's stories when
they were saying how difficult life was
and then when they came out life changed
you know it got better
and it was the some of the experiences
from other people I thought I'm next in
line it's it's my responsibility to help
others like others have helped me by
being visible being you know a football
player ex-football players played for
the German national team I want to be
that person that other people can refer
to and say well he was brave enough to
come out I can do it so that was more
responsibility because nowadays I don't
feel the urge to tell people about my
private life so much
it's more being that person who helps
others because I've been helped
that moment I said it would have been
great if I'd done it during my career I
would have liked to see how the The Lads
would react you know how the club would
react and the media but that wasn't the
case but six months after I retired I
just felt like it's got to happen now I
almost said like if I don't do it nobody
else will do it
uh but of course that's that's not true
but I felt the urge to do it and also
for me personally it's like I don't want
to carry that with me all the time and
having to think who knows it who doesn't
am I open can I open up to this group of
people it was just you know painful at
times like it's got to be said it's out
once and then never have to say it again
for me at the time when I did come out
it was a massive mental health thing
um you know it was dragging down my
football and that was my life and
you know I was just living kind of in an
adult Bubble at the time I was in and it
wasn't nice so that to start off was you
know I kind of want to get out of that
um I'm struggling to know who I am and
that's why I told mum and my sister
um then when it came out publicly for me
it was obviously I want everyone to know
the real me
um and I want to be an inspiration which
is kind of another reason why I did it
now you know
there's there is no one else in you know
British football that has that has come
out you know for me I do think there are
other footballers that are are gay in in
dressing rooms that
aren't coming out so for me it was to be
a massive inspiration and
keep the the group there that you know
people can
come out and feel safe and know that
there are players out there like myself
and obviously you
um that have done it and it is a safe
environment for them to do that it's a
great story you you you're true to
yourself you're an inspiration to others
and that to me was the most powerful
thing ever that suddenly people like get
in touch with me it's like you've helped
me you've changed my life and that is
just I hope you don't mind me saying
this sort of more powerful than scoring
a goal or winning a football match it's
just bigger than that and that's just
brilliant yeah I had the same messages
as well and yeah it's such an amazing
feeling to know that you know what what
you've done is encourage office to do
the same thing and that for me it was
you know I don't want people to be in
the same situation that I was where it's
where you're a bit confused it's to be
able to come out and you know seeing
their messages was was a very
inspirational moment before you came out
what was the lowest point for you and
and knowing you again
that's a difficult question because of
course it's not just a moment it's a
period you're going through you're
thinking okay I'm I'm gay you know what
I'm going to do now who who can I trust
are going to speak to and then you still
have to perform and you realize well I
realized I didn't perform I had injuries
um I couldn't get in the team at times
and you're moving clubs and every six or
12 months you move to a new club it's a
new environment and it takes time to to
build up a trust with other players and
I just couldn't make good enough friends
to say look this is who I am and
gradually come out that never happened
and there were moments in the dressing
room and I don't know whether you've
experienced this
when when players talked about it
hypothetically is there a gay football
player what would you do if if we had a
gay teammate and some of the things have
been said have were low moments for me
because suddenly players say you know if
we have a gay teammate I wouldn't shower
with him you know I wouldn't get changed
in the dressing room I was like really
is that what you would do and there were
some other things that have been said
that I thought you know I wouldn't want
to be open again in the stressing room
and that was was very frustrating to say
that just proves that the the dressing
room can be a tough environment I think
that obviously the lowest point was when
I was suffering mentally and that that
stemmed from me getting injured I wasn't
playing
um I stopped eating I wasn't speaking to
my my parents everything just kind of
went in such a different position and
you know I could see myself I wasn't the
person that I used to be like me and Mum
had the closest Bond and me and my
sister had such an amazing bun and then
that kind of went to nothing
um and it was a horrible feeling
um
obviously I got back fit but I wasn't
eating properly got injured again
literally first came back and I was back
in the same position uh and I just
wanted to
go away and that was where everything
came on top of me with me being gay and
then it was like I need to come out and
just be be fine with myself and that's
how I was you know it I've I've accepted
myself and I had for done for
a good I'd only say about three years
but only like a year before I came I
accept it with myself but
you know so happy that I did it what was
the reaction from the football Community
when when you both came out at the times
you did with me it was a surprise
um there are so many communities of
different football teams that have an
lgbtq Community within them
um so you know I've got Everton toffees
for example and
um Newcastle have there one which I know
and just seeing them and them sending me
videos you know Newcastle me videos and
I'm chanting in the bar my name and just
such a surreal moment because I never
knew I never researched it that there
were so many communities out there
um for each individual team and they're
all so supportive of it so it was such
an amazing feeling to see that I mean
personally there was no need from former
teammates to get in touch with me some
did they said you know well done yeah
Brave step you know coming out publicly
but very few in the end to be perfectly
honest the media was great you know but
of course you get some emails and
letters from people who don't like it
and I'm sure you've received some of
them but it didn't really hurt me
because I thought I've got nothing to be
ashamed of you know it's this is who I
am and if people don't like it then
they've got to get on with their
miserable life 100 I was really really
pleased that there was so few bad
reactions negative reactions up until to
this day uh very few people say
something negative
um I mean they might avoid me if they
don't like me and for what I stand for
uh but we've all experienced it social
media it can be quite tough for me the
biggest concern is always like being
criticized for what I'm doing not for
who I am because it's easy for me to say
look you know I'm not at fault at
anything I haven't done anything wrong
this is who I am get on with it but if
somebody criticized me for not being a
good football player or not working well
for my club then I have a problem and
that's what's happened ever since you
know people just disliked what I was
doing but very few said like you know
you being gay it's disgraceful whatever
it doesn't hurt me because I know for
myself I haven't done anything wrong
this is who I am that's it get on with
it
do you think there are any other gay men
in professional football right now
um that will be here I'm pretty sure
um it's always you know we talk about
statistics and and statistically that
there must be other gay football players
um but I I can't talk about it honestly
my ambition was to be there for for
those people who who are questioning
themselves whether they should come out
or not uh that's the only ambition but
other than that I don't know that there
probably will be of course statistically
but I don't know if any really yeah I
don't know of any
um I do think that there is I don't know
any
um but I just think it is look if if
there is you know you come out when
you're ready that you can't force
anything
um it's their choice but I do definitely
think that there is obvious in in
football that are gay what do you think
stopping more men in the professional
game to come out I'd say social media is
one massive thing
um being a footballer you know you'll
get targeted by other fans and I feel
like
being gay or
racism is such an easy target for
someone to Target you for
um that's someone can say you're a
rubbish player but if if you have come
out as gay that that would be the first
instinct to Target you on which will be
like shouting your gay on the pitch and
that'd be their first thing so and I
think for footballers having such a
massive
fan base
I feel like that is the main scare of it
is social media
um I always have said that masculinity
is a thing and you know in sport you
have to be
strong
um
and people I feel like people refer to
being gay as being weak which is
obviously not it but
I would put I think social media is just
the biggest thing I would say yeah I
agree however it's interesting what you
said about the dressing room because
what I when I look back I think that was
part of the reason What stopped me or
what made me wait longer because I would
have felt extremely uncomfortable in the
dressing room I told you about you know
what people said hypothetically what
they would do not the fans Not the media
I'm Gonna Leave Out social media but
media are kind of sense that would be
very positive fans we discussed it you
know they're they're much further
Advanced a lot of people think they are
but it's a dressing room you know you go
there every day and if there is a player
or two that are uncomfortable you know
getting changed in the same dressing
room then it's an issue it affects you
know training it affects the games the
results so I did not want to be
responsible for that that was part of
the reason do you think there's anything
that could be done
um that would
Inspire more men to come out in the
professional game
nowadays I'd say that a lot of clubs do
good work you know they know they can't
be against gay people in football you
know we see the rainbow Flags
um and and symbolism has definitely
become bigger and bigger but in the end
it's a personal story it's a face to it
yeah and that's why it's so powerful to
to say I'm one of them you know I I lead
the way that's what you can do and and
create an environment where it it
becomes easier to come out you know when
the clubs constantly say that you know
their pro-diversity and of course they
would support gay football players if
they want to come out at their own club
and and allies you know other football
players who say well obviously I'm not
gay but you know I would support gay gay
football players if if he was my
teammate great I'd support him those
sort of personal stories but in the end
the most powerful thing is people like
you who say I'm gay and I'm a football
player and I'll do the best every day
yeah yeah I think the exact same thing
you know you can't force someone to come
out do you think club's doing such an
amazing thing at the moment to make it
inclusive
um but I do feel like when more people
come out we will get a roll-on effect
and it'll be become more easier for
people and then that's what will change
change it full-on generally do you think
there is a homophobia problem in
football
I wouldn't say home like a homophobia
problem
um obviously you can't
stop people from being homophobic that
you you physically can't stop someone
from shouting your game on the pitch or
something like that so
I feel like it it is a difficult
position to be in in that respect I
don't think football's worse than the
rest of the society the issue with
football is it's just so public you know
we see so much football every day on on
TV
um so the impression is more happens in
football it's homophobic in other areas
but the rest of society you know it
doesn't take place on TV every day or on
social media every day that's why I
believe in from my own experience that
football can be tough of course it's not
perfect people who people there are
people who behave inappropriately they
insult others but from from everything
I've seen and experienced the last 20 30
years it's it's not worse it's going the
right direction and yes what you said is
a really good example they give people
the opportunity to report a bad behavior
but in general
football is not worse than other areas
of course it's not better than other
areas but it's just in the public eye
all the time and that's why we're here
and see more of it do you think football
authorities could be doing more to help
the lgbtq community in professional
football well you can always do more but
since we both say that we haven't
experienced it to a larger degree and
that that's a good sign we are in the
public eye and and whenever something
happens it can get reported in people's
seed and there will be sanctions so
clubs and and federations they've moved
forward as I said when I look at the
bigger picture and in global football
development is not always to my King but
you know I I guess FIFA Nueva it's it's
on their agenda but they can't really
bring everything together on the one
hand they're trying to promote you know
a discrimination free football
and at the same time they it these
events take place in countries where
homosexuality is is forbidden that is a
problem that's why there's so much
discussion going on still and and will
be in the future that's very complicated
but
there is a lot of people and here again
I think social media can be a very
positive where they say look this is
unacceptable we need to do something
about it and keep up the pressure
pressure on clubs and federations to say
okay we've got to change this football
is for everybody it's inclusive and and
don't say it's inclusive when it really
helps you and and leave it out on other
occasions yeah different things are
changing and you know that their
football in general is is getting better
um obviously things like the World Cup
you know they happen and don't get me
wrong I was a bit frustrated with with
the World Cup being held in Qatar but
you know it does happen so
I feel like it isn't in a good place and
it's it's definitely going forward
what is the biggest positive impact or
change you've felt since coming out for
me like we've said it's seen you've
helped other people be able to come out
and that is such a massive it's a
massive feeling when you do see that
um especially for myself as well you
know I I found myself and that was one
of the main things for me was to find my
true self and I haven't I've been able
to do that comfortably and be surrounded
by so many amazing people around me that
I find I've got a partner I've got new
friends that are also accepting and
that's just the main thing I could have
asked for it's similar with me it's just
the confidence you know you gain so much
more confidence and being at ease with
myself I don't have to worry about who
am I talking to about what it's just I'm
myself it's exactly the same and then
adding to that where you said uh yeah
being a role model it's not something I
want to be in the first place but then
you realize the impact you have
and and that is fantastic but in general
just being happy with myself being
confident at ease with who I am yeah
what advice would you give if any to
anybody that's been in a similar
position to yourselves particularly
including in in the professional game
well I would say don't risk your health
you know if you get to that point where
where you risk in your health because
you think you can't come out then you
should reconsider that it's just not
worth it uh football players are often
being told like you have a career of 10
or 15 years that's where you've got to
make your money and live of it and I
think that's really really bad to say
that your life's more than those 15
years of course they're exceptional if
it's 15 years it's wonderful you've got
to enjoy every moment of it but life
means more than those 15 years so you've
got to see the bigger picture and just
don't do anything stupid or you know
listen to yourself your body obviously
tells you if you're in a bad State then
that's what you've done that's what I
would say and look at the the positive
attributes try to find people who
encourage you people who really help you
and say coming out can be daunting can
be tough but look this is what you're
going to gain some positives use example
of other people and hopefully that will
help yeah the main the main one for me
was just being able to speak out about
the first time I ever told someone
obviously it was my mum and my sister
but the relief of my shoulders even
though it is a saying I literally did
feel that and I was dancing around the
room and it was such an amazing feeling
so it's you know it might be difficult
to be able to speak to someone about
such a personal thing because you know
it's a secret it's your life secret is
what it is
um but if you can speak out do it
because it is such an amazing thing and
you will feel more relaxed more accepted
and comfortable within yourself and what
are your hopes for the future of the
lgbtq plus community in the professional
game
yeah I think for me is to see more
players come out as gay you know
obviously the amount of Benny's gay but
the person I do think there is and it is
to see more footballers more Sports
people come out and have that that
circle of people and make it bigger and
bigger and bigger as such a community
that you know people can come out be
accepting and for me that is the main
thing it's just to see that that
positive change which I do think is on
the horizon I I sincerely hope that we
kind of move on and and we don't always
have to answer the same questions and
that's what would happen to me you know
for 10 years I've been answering the
same question since like let's just move
on and and it being a natural part of
life you know somebody like you is is
there and you don't have to give answers
all the time and say what about what was
it like and and all those sort of things
and in the end it is what you said more
people to live openly gay in in the
professional football world and then um
you know and as I said they talk about
their Partners they don't come out and
say I'm gay and then next moment I have
a partner this has come out like every
other footballer straight footballer say
just got engaged or divorced or whatever
ended being an natural part of it and
not having to go through that it's a big
coming out video interview and then
everybody wants to know what what
happens next it being natural yeah
so I was taken into a darkened room no
windows
um sat in a chair a wooden chair this
arm was strapped with leather straps to
the chair I had electrodes which they
had soaked in salt water
placed on my arms stuck on my arm